j'aimerais répondre aux malentendus qui
a échauffé ce week-end quelques esprits
peut-être en mal de politiques je dois
dire que je peine à comprendre quel
intérêt aurait eu la grande distribution
a caché des stocks de masques au lieu de
les vendre en temps de pénurie il n'ya
pas il n'y a jamais eu de stock caché il
y a des commandes massives et il faut un
certain temps avant qu'elle se
concrétise en millions de masques
disponibles pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens pour tous ceux qui pensent
qu'il suffit de commander des masques
pour les obtenir
j'ai un long historique dont je peux
faire état mais ce qui compte pour
l'instant c'est que le 11 mai chacun
puisse se procurer des masques dans les
commerces situés près de chez lui nous
avons écouté les associations d'élus et
nous resterons extrêmement attentif à
toutes les remontées du terrain
l'état et les collectivités locales
assureront la protection de leur
personnel l'état financera 50 % des
masques grand public que sont en train
de se procurer les collectivités à leurs
demandes
j'ai décidé de prendre en charge de
façon rétroactive une partie du coût de
ses achats pour les commandes passées à
compter du 13 avril dernier et j'ai
appelé les collectivités qui en ont les
moyens à faire preuve de solidarité
envers les communes qui les entourent ou
les plus petites collectivités l'état
réservera en outre une enveloppe
hebdomadaire de 5 millions de masques
grand public pour les plus vulnérables
de nos concitoyens il reviendra au
préfet avec les maires les présidents de
conseils départementaux d'organiser la
distribution des masques à nos
concitoyens les plus précaires
via par exemple les ccas et les acteurs
associatifs
par ailleurs les régions et l'état vont
accroître leur soutien aux très petites
entreprises et aux travailleurs
indépendants au delà des initiatives
déjà prises par certaines branches ou
organisations professionnelles une
plateforme de e-commerce d'être par
ailleurs mis en place par la poste dont
je tiens ici à saluer la mobilisation à
nos côtés le succès du déconfinement
repose ensuite sur notre capacité à
tester à isoler les personnes atteintes
du coc vie de 19 depuis la semaine
dernière les élus les préfets et les
directeurs généraux des ars dispose des
éléments leur permettant de planifier la
levée du confinement
c'est à l'échelle de chaque département
que se déploiera 7
formé de trois maillons puisqu'elle
commencera avec les tests se poursuivra
avec le traçage des éventuelles
contaminations et s'achèvera le cas
échéant par l' isolement des personnes
contaminées
les tests virologiques sont le fer de
lance de notre stratégie de dépistage
nous voulons nous devons tester d'une
part tous ceux qui présenteront des
symptômes similaires à ceux du comité 19
et d'autre part ceux de leurs contacts
présentant un risque élevé de
contamination qu'il soit symptomatique
ou non
quand nous avons établi les modalités du
déconfinement le conseil scientifique
nous indiquait que les modèles
épidémiologiques
prévoyez entre 1000 et 3000 nouveaux cas
par jour à partir du 11 mai à chaque
nouveau cas correspondre à en moyenne le
test d'au moins 20 à 25 personnes
personne ayant croisé dans les jours
précédant celui qui a été testé positif
3000 cas nouveaux nous prenons l'échelle
haute que nous ont donné les
scientifiques 25 à contacter nous
prenons l'échelle moyenne haute que nous
donnent les scientifiques 3000 x 25 x 7
cela donne 525 milles test par semaine
si on est bien dans les hypothèses sur
lesquelles nous avons travaillé nous
nous sommes fixé l'objectif de réaliser
non pas 5 125 mille tests par semaine
les sept cent mille tests virologiques
par semaine à partir du 11 mai nous
voulons avoir une marge ou qu'a duré un
peu plus de cas nouveaux que ce sur quoi
nous comptons et nous voulons également
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre en plus des
tests des chaînes de contamination des
campagnes de dépistage comme nous
l'avons déjà engagés pour les ehpad
notamment les laboratoires publics
privés de recherche et laboratoires
vétérinaires sont mobilisés pour que ces
tests soient accessibles à partir du 11
mai surtout nos territoires
l'assurance les malades maladie les
prendra en charge à 100%